here's how to get really really good at
copyrighting fast number one write as
much as you scroll if you scroll two
hours a day you're writing two hours a
day number two is read an ad every
single day especially the ones that made
you buy something okay find out what
channel that energy the emotions you
felt why you bought it go back and study
that ad channel the energy number three
is unsubscribe from any Guru that tells
you that copyrighting is some getrich
quick scheme it's not they're messing
with your mentality you need to put in
the hard work and get ready to do the
hard work okay number four is start a
daily email list around your passion
whether you're into football basketball
copyrighting magazines Fitness whatever
it is get a daily email list for the
sake of Simply writing an email every
single day number five is read read read
read read okay ogal Von advertising
breakthrough advertising the adwe
copyrighting handbook whatever you can
get your hands on